couldiaty bull kindy bonjour
bonjour merci d'être avec nous ce matin
en direct sur rt france alors pour
commencer peut-être quel est le climat
aujourd'hui dans les rues de ouagadougou
quelques jours après le coup d'état
bien à voir avec le goût tout et tout
est calme à part le couvre-feu qui a
limité un peu un tant soit peu leur
liberté
actuellement tout tout tout le temps
oracle où la vie reprend normalement son
cours à ouagadougou ainsi que dans toute
la vie
du burkina faso comment est ce que la
population at elle vécu ce coup d'état
ce qu'il ya un soutien aujourd'hui à la
jante est ce que le peuple est divisé
quant est-il
le peuple n'est pas divisée du moins
ceux visiblement parce que
ce n'est pas comme les coups d'état
intérieur ou un allegro et le contre et
à tout cas jusqu'à présent on ne voit
pas on voit pas de groupe ou de partis
politiques qui s'y opposent alors donc
on ne peut pas parler de division à
partir du moment où manifestement on ne
voit personne se lève et
se mettre au travers de ce
questionnement roma qui vient de prendre
le pouvoir alors on le disait les
dirigeants de la cedeao vont se réunir
aujourd'hui à accra pour décider
d'éventuelles sanctions supplémentaires
contre le burkina faso à une réunion
après une visite de deux missions
envoyées en début de semaine qu'est ce
qu'on peut retenir de cette visite il y
avait des missions de l'onu est
également de la cedeao qu'est ce qu'il
en ressort
rien le grana est sorti officiellement
mais cette visite
après donc la suspension du burkina les
instances de la cedeao
une ville aux portes avec la junte est
certainement
ce pour le garder pour les écouter afin
de voir s'ils voient accorder leurs
violons ils vont s'accorder le violent
et
la suite ce sera ce qui va sortir de la
bouche ou alors la géante qui a rétabli
la constitution la constitution qu'elle
avait suspendu le 24 janvier comment se
positionne justement la jante vis-à-vis
de la cedeao est ce qu'il ya une volonté
de dialogue
bien sûr qu'il ya une volonté de
dialogue la constitution avait été
suspendue elle est revenu
fort avec naturellement que des
retouches je crois que le dialogue avec
la zone n'est pas interrompue mais tout
va dépendre
je crois bien que de lui de ce qui va
sortir de la rencontre d'aujourd'hui si
la cba aubrac évidemment ça sera on va
assister certainement et sans doute
jeudi
au scénario malien
justement il ya une délégation de l'onu
qui haussier est allé sur place et pour
les émissaires internationaux la junte
je les cite est très ouverte aux
discussions on a quand même le sentiment
du ciel d'une situation un peu moins
crispé qu'au mali ou au niger est ce que
c'est le cas effectivement et si oui
pour quelles raisons
bien sûr que à l'appel du pouvoir par
les armes le le le le nouveau pouvoir à
7/10 des stages dans sa première
déclaration il s'est dit ouvert aux
alors communauté internationale avec
laquelle naturellement elle va revendre
mais vous parlez pas que la jeune qu'eux
au pouvoir aujourd'hui au burkina n'est
pas allée pas dans une logique de les
partager les t2 de
crispation
c'est plutôt
isla jeu s'est mise dans une case une
logique d'ouverture et de dialogue
ouverture et dialogue donc au niveau
international au niveau national
également puisqu'il ya les partis
politiques qui ont été reçu avant-hier
bien sûr j'allais partie le la junte a
jugé nécessaire de rencontrer
d'ailleurs ses passes se passe le mal
est parti politique la junte en train de
faire une consultation large pour voir
le schéma où le format qu'il faut donner
à à
à la gouvernance burkina faso fera que
les consultations se poursuivent voilà
pourquoi j'ai dit
c'est une jeune qui s'est inscrite dans
une dynamique de dialogue de
concertation et d'ouverture du coup à
quoi s'attendre dans les prochains jours
les prochains mois dans le sillage de
cette volonté de dialogue justement
les burkinabè savent toujours dialoguer
et je vous rappelle que
aller sélection dès 2014 on était
presque au bout du cacao mais les
burkinabè ont toujours su se mettre
ensemble malgré les divergences pour
construire le vivre ensemble et je crois
que l'on peut s'attendre à au même
scénario avec le la junte au pouvoir
aujourd'hui c'est d'autant plus que
cette ce nouveau pouvoir s'est montrée a
montré toute sa volonté lors que de
talent et au dialogue et au coin ça
passe avant de conclure peut-être un mot
quelles sont les nouvelles concernant le
président déchu que marc christian
kaboré
j'ai pas
je pas vraiment de nouvelles
à proprement parler mais la vie à la
ville pour la vie le président et
apparaît
dans les médias
recevant
les diplomates venus donc de 2
jeux partout pour un 5e rue de ses
nouvelles donc on espère qu il va très
bien il se porte très bien et d'ailleurs
c'est ce qui a été dit officiellement le
président à son intégrité physique
et morale
sont très bien assurée et donc il ya pas
de foule un grand merci pour votre
éclairage koulidiati bull kindy je le
rappelle vous êtes journaliste directeur
de publication de quetta au point net